need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was designed to help
you overcome the number one challenge
that is holding you back a lack of
belief in yourself so get ready for some
champion mindset wisdom from Kawhi
Leonard to give you the motivation
confidence and belief that you need
ok let's kick it off with rule number
one trust yourself
what has the last two years taught you
changed you to get from there to here
and just always trusting yourself that's
what I learned you know you know once
things go bad there's only so many
people that is gonna be on you on your
side man just that's it just really
trusting yourself and just keep working
now kind of faith and you know good
things happen to good people
rule number two have a champions mindset
you know a lot of our games this year
came down to this last stretch
fortunately I didn't it would help us
every time but with me it's just my
mindset just being able to still take
the last shot or you know take the shot
starter be good to down a stretch it
doesn't bother me if I miss or make it
so I'll just keep going and uh you know
I think the next one always long going
rule number three don't care what others
say a lot of people were doubting me you
know thought I was either faking an
injury or didn't want to play for a team
you know that was disappointing to me
that all that was out in the media
because I love the game of basketball
like I always say if we're not playing
his games is and for hurt I mean you're
down doesn't matter what anybody has to
say about me I Know Who I am as a person
I know how I feel and always just trust
yourself and that was my goal and my
focus and you know that's why did it one
of the things that you know I take on
the floor I don't care about what media
has to say about me or one if they want
me to score whatever thirty points
because I did the game before I'm gonna
come out and play the right way I'm not
trying to make headlines and you know
those that's just things that you know I
pretty much learned just throughout this
journey of being in a MBA and so I mean
that's this hub just keep growing up as
a man name unless why say I just think
about my past life and try to learn from
situations and be and be wise and learn
from others rule number four work hard
you came out of San Diego State and
there were some doubters who were like I
doesn't have a mid rage game you worked
your butt off here in town actually a
couple of places across town and
eventually you your game took off and
you showed it your first season up with
the Spurs oh yeah so a lot of people
just didn't quite didn't think I could
score the ball coming out at Sunday to
go stay so it'll just work extremely
hard on my jump shot in just my whole
offensive game just so I could get easy
points and you know it worked out for me
a tissue shot the ball better than I did
in college and I'm trying to move on for
and it gave me a better player fire that
ball to Johnny Simms and no one
also if you want to have more confidence
check on my 254 series it's free the
link to join is in the description below
try to trace my evolution and I'm with a
Michael Jordan evolution that always had
to start back in college hitting a shot
against Georgetown in 1982 and I really
didn't know exactly what I was doing if
you wake up in the morning and you're
dreading going to work dude do something
else do something else and those are
hard decisions to make but when you make
those decisions it's a very liberating
experience rule number five learn to say
no just being able to just separate
myself from you know my friends at times
just going going to the gym or just
reading at a you know extra book or
studying for tests SATs or just even a
math test that you have to pass and you
know just just doing that just just
listening to myself getting away from I
mean my friends either telling me let's
go to this party or go here just being
able to say no and you know focus on
with who I wanted to become rule number
six impress everyone
to me
San Diego State
I'm siesta most people did
fifteen overall
Yuni competitor is
Zordon
San Diego State small conference in law
school same as myself yeah that kind of
hard to really make it to succeed in a
peer so I know what it takes to he wants
to dominate on both sides at f/4 he
wants to be special on both sides of
that floor
and you know he's he's skilled and
gifted to do so that's what I really
respect about his game he's ridiculous
one of the best two-way players in the
game
is defensive ability to shut guys down
one through four is incredible
rule number seven go through adversity
and you went into these playoffs I don't
know if you were the team you were at
the end of this playoffs you guys grew
over the past two months what do you
think you sort of clicked in the most
and learned to do the most with each
other I feel like we kind of where'd his
team know like just from the startup
playoffs we lost to Landrum attic
somebody had a game-winner DJ Augustin
and you know just from there how we
bounce back one fourth straight four
straight and then you know I feel like
we just played through adversity this
whole time throughout the whole playoffs
going to what Philly Knicks
and we're down to one and game got Game
four we played through that one that out
man you know the next series with by the
way look how casually he says that we
won that out because the ball that the
shot that he took and the ball bounced
on this trip I mean we won nothing less
we don't we're not going right
everything happened for a reason 87 on
the game seven with Philly and then
Milwaukee losing to everybody thinking
it's over then we want a fourth straight
and then you know coming here obviously
they wasn't no at their full strength
but it felt like we played like three
different teams you know with clay being
out in Game three and then
you know Katie coming back Game five
just like three different teams and we
just played through adversity it was a
blessing for me to just be in his finals
and have two days off in between games
it held my neo
like I said we just been playing through
adversity throughout the whole year like
like I said the things behind the scenes
don't nobody know about with injuries
with me being out you know kalo wood is
back early on rule number eight be
relentless about improvement one word to
describe quiet Leonard relentless he's
got a look and he's just gonna go and
attack him he won't stop the thing that
Kauai possesses that every truly special
player has is a burning desire to get
better my dad helped me out with my work
ethic he always told me anyone gonna go
the way he had to go through my life to
be easier than his he made me just work
hard for he wanted in what all women
rule number nine give credit to your
team
you're obviously known that's someone
known for their defense how special was
it to receive the MVP award from Bill
Russell I was very special obviously I
didn't come out in this series Shauna
Winnie you know it was a whole group
collectively tonight Fred played amazing
in that for Kyle played amazing tonight
throughout the whole game pascale play
big and you know I just kept driving in
you know pushing and you know I ended up
with the trophy but everybody deserves
it
and rule number ten the last one before
a very special bonus clip is have fun
say thank you walk over here
after the tray with open doors man it
made my experience that much better this
group of guys let me do what I do on the
floor close to me let me do what I do
and now we got a champion shoe
thank you and like they said enjoy it is
enjoy this moment and have fun with
[Applause]
now I've got a special bonus tip from
Kauai on how to be dedicated that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one where do you need to
be relentless about improving yourself
number two what do you need to say no to
and number three what does a Champions
mindset mean to you I mean just keep
working hard you know it's not always
about being an all-star just become who
you want to become and want to be in
this league and you know work at it and
you know don't tell nobody you can't do
it I already dedicate basically you know
my whole my whole life about a
basketball and you know be able to go to
the gym all those extra hours are going
are going to just playing a better game
and
if you want to see the top 10 I did on
Kevin Durant check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
I've been through the toughest times
with my family you better I'm still
standing it was kind of tough knowing
that